ladies and gentlemen we are approaching
the three-year anniversary of when the
first new mutant trailer came out and
now they're
coming to comic-con at home
i don't care what people say everyone's
like they should just put it on
streaming
no no no this movie
should come out in the theaters july
18th it's earned it
it has struggled its way to getting
released yeah
and it's gonna overcome every obstacle
and even if it bombs at the box office
it should go in the theaters okay i'll
open if it's the last thing i do
and if it goes out on streaming directly
i'm gonna buy a theater just to put it
in there
put it in the driveway the only one
forget tenant
new mutants let's watch
you're not this anywhere
this place takes your greatest fears
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
cool
oh i won't oh we're gonna watch it live
we got press badges for the first time
and they're not
they're not going to waste not on
comic-con at home
which i'm sure you guys will be able to
see pretty much what we're going to see
at the same time i mean with all the
trailers they've had
and photos they've released they're
running tight on what they can unveil
before spoiling the entire movie at this
point
there's another trailer on the way i
don't know what they're gonna put in you
get some teases of like the limbo
dimension
uh looking at magic sword um the mirage
character as well so you get some cool
little looks
at this point the entire nebulous of
everything i'm saying i don't give a
[ __ ] if this movie is bad or not
at this point it deserves to come out in
the theaters
and i am championing for it everyone
deserves closure
yeah around this brunch i wonder if the
humor will feel misplaced i feel like it
should have a bit of a self-aware sense
of humor i don't remember the other
trailers
showcasing that kind of humor as well
this had a kind of weird tonal jarring
thing
of it's so dark so monster supernatural
effects heavy
and then some like marvel quips you look
back at that last teaser we watched
that last trailer that was kind of what
i was wondering about was like when
disney first got whatever cut they got i
have no idea at this point what got
re-shot or didn't but they
apparently weren't happy and i certainly
could imagine them inserting some of
that marvel humor and i mean that seemed
to be this kind of reminded me of that
they fly now trailer but in a more
palatable way than
they fly now star wars trailer i'm
excited to see the panel and i hope they
asked them
some bold questions about the amounts of
delays and ask them all the questions
that have been on fans minds you know
like make it clear because josh boone
has addressed so much of it already the
whole cast is supposed to be there so
let's ask them all the bold questions
don't be [ __ ] at this at home event
seriously
it's gonna be the most like production
heavy question don't make it that game
of thrones comic-con panel you know like
do some real questions that way people
can you know just
get it addressed i think any taylor joy
is gonna absolutely steal the show
i mean she's the main character and she
looks like she's gonna absolutely
deliver guys what do you think of this
are you still excited for new mutants
subscribe click that notification bell
and last but not least
i'm gonna keep this short j and valente
i'm gonna keep this real short
i don't know where you've been i'm
trying to find you for months now are
you
locked up in some type of weird mutant
experimental facility or something i
appreciate you staying pledged and this
is your shout out
and this will be your kind of shout outs
for the remainder
of the time you you give us the silent
treatment until you send us some notes
so that we can go back and do some
reshoots
yeah new music take all those videos
down
just for you just for a better shout out
for you